[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
on the 13th of October I'm Cindy Yu The
Spectators broadcast editor coming up on
the show
the destruction of kirchbridge in
Chromeo was yet another setback for
Putin in his war with Ukraine I speak to
Owen Matthews and Dimitri albarovich
about whether the president's position
is secure and what he could do next but
ukrainians have already suffered
retaliation with hundreds of missiles
launched at the country this week I
speak to you Svetlana mourinitz about
the pattern of Putin's attacks back home
let's trust is also a leader in a
position of weakness I'm joined by James
Forsyth Katie Bose and Isabelle Hardman
to discuss whether the mood in the
conservative party has rather
unbelievably got even worse
we'll also be giving you a sneak preview
of Katie's interview with Fiona Hill
Theresa May is former Chief of Staff who
along with Nick Timothy was blamed for a
lot of where May's Premiership went
wrong
over in China another National Party
Congress is about to start giving Xi
Jinping at least another five years in
power I talked to Charles Parton about
China's president for life
and finally what happened to a more
elegant period of train travel on the
show Peter Hitchens reminisces about the
London to Paris Golden Arrow and we ask
does everything have to be so great and
functional with these days
this episode is sponsored by candy code
genuity wealth management experience
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times visit can do wealth
for more information
and why not subscribe to our YouTube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
first up is Putin's Kremlin showing
cracks Russia has suffered numerous
setbacks in recent weeks the latest
being the humiliating destruction of
Kirch bridge in Crimea Owen Matthews
writes this week's cover article
explaining the factional Rivalry within
the Russian Elite he joins the show now
together with foreign policy analyst
Dimitri aberovich
so Owen and Dimitri welcome to spectator
TV
um to start with Owen can you tell us
about this video that you start your
article writing about this week um what
are we seeing here
the video
um is uh filmed by an anonymous person
um a mobilized Soldier uh complaining
very vociferously and actually shouting
uh about the conditions in which they
they the new mobilized
um reservists have been living and he
pans around and he says at the beginning
there are 500 of us we've been we are we
are armed we don't know where we're
going they're obviously on their way to
somewhere because there's literally a
train standing right next to them and
various other members of that group most
of them who are masked are shouting you
know and we've been living and the
officers are treating us like like uh
like farm animals you know we we we've
been buying our own food and so on but
the reason why I cite this video is
actually not what it obviously says but
what it none obviously says because if
you look at it carefully in fact several
of the people in the video in fact one
person is very prominent of the video is
wearing the patches of the Wagner Group
which is a military company which has
received a huge amount of funding and
support from the Kremlin and has been
recruiting all over uh very actively
including from prisons recruiting people
for Putin's war in Ukraine and crucially
this video was distributed through
telegram channels associated with the
head of that private military company so
it's not just a video about discontented
mobilized reservists it's a video of
somebody who has a private military
company
trying to discredit the Russian Ministry
of defense and that I thought was a good
starting point to discuss the various
sort of cracks that are appearing in and
the criticism that's being leveled at
the conduct of the war and so far that
criticism has been leveled at the
Minister of Defense at the generals and
so on it has not yet been leveled at
Putin and the top of the Kremlin but the
question I explore in my piece is you
know
at what point does that criticism move
beyond the prosecution of the war and of
of the kremlin's leadership instead
instead and oh and I think it's
important to say that this criticism
um that you're talking about
specifically doesn't come from a
pacifist perspective you know that
they're they're Ultra nationalism I
write in saying that and they want they
think that their problem with the wars
that hasn't been conducted efficiently
enough successfully enough not that the
war shouldn't happen
uh well that's a broader question if
we're looking at the whole spectrum of
opposition to Putin
um I think what's underappreciated in
the west is that
um Alexander van Lee
um who has been in jail obviously in
Siberia now um uh speaks for a certain
section of the opposition but he doesn't
speak for the most dangerous section of
the opposition which is the
alternationalists who think that Putin
has not been Prosecuting this War uh
with sufficient Vigor and actually
that's the constituency which I think
worries the Kremlin and the people who
are form what you might call a
collective Putin the decision-making
that very small decision-making Clique
at the top of the Kremlin they're much
more worried about the nationalists and
the criticism and the political threat
from the right than from the pro navani
pro-western liberals who oppose the war
um who else I suppose you could call
them on the political left
Dimitri um
what have we already seen Putin trying
to appease this wing of
um the political Dynamic by becoming
more aggressive himself by repeating
some of their demands um in other words
is he going to be escalating because
it's being prodded and shoved into ever
stronger positions
you know I actually don't think that
Putin is very much concerned about
criticism that's coming from the right
in fact this is a timeline tradition not
just in punish government but frankly in
many governments in both Soviet and
zarist era in Russia where you encourage
divisions within your group of advisors
and and infighting so that no one
becomes too strong and I'm sure that
um Putin is um not necessarily upset
that pagosian and kadera the head of
chachnia regarding of course the head of
Wagner a criticizing defense minister
shorygu and the head of uh general staff
gerasimov putting more pressure on them
is something that Putin may actually
like
um because he he's very well aware that
the war is not being prosecuted well but
I think his decision to Annex the
territories before oblasts in Ukraine a
couple of weeks ago was really key
because it was a metaphorical burning of
the boats there is no turning back from
that he can't politically just unannex
them and pretend it never happened
there's obviously been a change in
Russian Constitution to to incorporate
these oblasts and
um you know if you're someone who is
even considering opposing Putin you can
necessarily run on a platform of undoing
that you don't want to be going into the
Russian history into the animals Russian
history saying that you are the one that
gave up lands Uh Russian lands newly
conquered Russian lands history is
usually not kind to those sorts of
people so I think that was a way for
Putin to shore up support to make it
less likely that there will be
opposition and to actually signal to
people within his government that were
getting wobbly about this war including
even those in the ministry of defense
that were lobbying him to abandon
certain parts of the territory we know
that for example in her song the
minister of defense was asking him to
withdraw because their position on that
um
uh uh side of the river is becoming
untenable and not only did he say no but
um with this annexation he basically
signaled to them you're going to fight
for every inch of these oblasts there
that are now ostensibly Russian um
territory um that he's uh proclaimed
through that action
Dimitri do you think Putin is still in
control
contrition
well to the extent that anyone is in
control obviously you know if you look
at the military situation things are
going from bad to worse for him he's
continuing to lose ground uh but in
terms of his power base in Russia I
think it's still very much secure
there's no uh uh natural leader
opposition leader there's no Lenin
there's no Yeltsin that could organize
the coup against him he is insured uh
that that all opposition
um like that would be eliminated either
through assassinations that he has
conducted over the course of the last
two decades or gln people or Exile in
them so I think he's feeling very secure
of course I have to note that coups are
always very very unlikely right up until
the moment they actually happen so it's
impossible to predict the future but um
I don't think that it's particularly
likely at this point Evan
yeah I I think um
um I think uh Dimitri is absolutely on
the money I think that's right um but I
think it is it's worthwhile
differentiating
um I mean there are coups from there are
coups from without and cruise from
within so I mean I completely agree that
um Putin has a very deep and very
powerful political resource behind him
the machine that he's built up both in
in terms of media manipulation and of
you know repression and and State
control is enormously efficient and he's
actually done a fantastically good job
of
bringing the country with him and uh
furthermore
there's been you know 20 years of
brainwashing about the dangers of change
and how terrible revolutionary changes
in Russia and they don't really even
need to mess with Russians of a certain
age they need to hear it from the
television they themselves they felt it
on their own hides in the Russian phrase
they saw the 1990s in a revolution and
revolutionary change and change of power
is actually in a very a much more scary
thing to most Russians than it is to the
West because for the obvious reasons
that historically that has not been a
how you know an easy or successful
process in twice in the 20th century so
the Russians are there there's actually
a profound there's a very strong
um Power resource that Putin still
controls however
there's a problem he himself is of
course created this problem and he's
painted himself into the into a corner
in the sense that
um before I mean over the summer he
could have he really could have after
he'd taken this a chance because you
know he you know he was on a roll he
could have said declared Victory you
know basically sort of pretended nothing
had happened and said like we're
starting a peace process and that would
definitely have split the Allies it
really would have because you know
macron would have come in to do his
macaron thing like in his sort of you
know peace and you know the the uh but
instead of doing that he did what Putin
has you know uh you know Putin uh always
does which is
escalate escalate in a really stupid way
so therefore what he's done is is he's
made his political career Hostage to
political to to to to to to to defeat in
the field and that's tactically a very
stupid thing to do because like why
would you want to risk your entire
regime over whether parts of his son are
part of Ukraine or part of Russia
literally no one cares except that
you're creating schools they care about
I mean in terms of the Russian Elite no
one cares about those details but Putin
as Dimitri rightly said has suddenly
made that a matter of life and death for
his regime so the the one caveat of this
picture of his the strength of his power
and the his his hold on the Russian
people's psyche and on the security
apparatus the one caveat to that is if
he suffers catastrophic religious defeat
in the field and at that point you
actually The Strain on the on the the
entire system becomes enormous and
unlike like in the Soviet Union
unlike in 1950 and 1964 when say the
party moved to remove to to to to remove
Nikita khrushoff from Power there's no
institutions it's just people it's just
what the Russians called pineated it's
understanding it's just like a group of
old mates who run Russia there was no
institution but
there's no institutional way or
constitutional way in which there could
be really be a reasonable Handover of
power but again that situation will only
happen if there is catastrophic energy
to feed well that's the point that's I
think really sticks with me Owen because
you know coming aside you looking at
things often from the Chinese
perspective I've been looking at the
party Congress that's coming up um next
week where seizing ping is almost
certain
um to renew his um power at the same
time the Chinese Communist party with
its 92 million members it's such a
massive institution that even C has to
sometimes bow to it so that if he goes
there will be others who follow Dimitri
what does succession look like in this
system in this environment that Putin
has built up
well if you look at the history of
Russian coups you need the support
particularly in the Soviet era you need
the support of the intelligence services
or elements of the intelligence Services
they don't necessarily the ones uh
historically are the ones that take
power but um their support is often
crucial so
um it's most likely to be someone that
is uh still a strong man that has the
confidence of those people maybe once
was part of their apparatus
um you know someone like uh
um uh uh Nikolai Patra Chev uh currently
the head of the security Council and
other old FSB colleague of Vladimir
Putin actually replaced him as ahead of
the FSB and and used to work with him in
the KGB back in the in the 70s and 80s
he is of course uh even more Hardline
than Putin so
um you know if if there is a change I'm
not sure it necessarily will
um uh indicate a change of power policy
vis-a-vis Ukraine because people are
going to be much more hard aligned and
by the way the example that Ian just
brought up with the who against Nikita
khrushoff and actually Khrushchev uh
replacing Stalin you've seen a more
hard-line policy develop vis-a-vis the
West you know Stalin dies and who shall
comes to power and then we get the Cuban
Missile Crisis because Khrushchev
decides the needs to escalate and show
himself to be a straw man so
um the history does not indicate that
we're in for a Rosy scenario here and
just finally I want to get both of your
thoughts on the possible escalation the
next steps because we've talked about
how Putin escalates
um has and has done so far
everyone is worried about nuclear
weapons and a tactical Nuclear Strike in
Ukrainian territory Owen to start with
do you think that is the next step or
could that happen
we'll put it this way
um over the last 10 days
um two things have happened last two
weeks two things have happened that have
I've been
watching Russia more or less all my life
I've been doing it this year
professionally for like 30 years two
things blew my mind and terrified me for
the first time in a lifetime
professional and lifetime watching
Russia that was the destruction of the
north stream pipelines and the uh that
was really quite extraordinarily I mean
I haven't seen any kind of real
reasonable scenario whereby anyone other
than the Russians did that to themselves
I mean perhaps they didn't but that
would be in even matter conspiracy
theory than the one that says that they
did I mean that's
indicates to me that there is something
very profoundly scarily
a miss and there's a very profound
disconnect between you know actual you
know rationality and reality and the
information that's that and and
realities on the ground and the behavior
of the Kremlin and the special services
that basically control have controlled
the the the the Kremlin for for decades
so in a world where Russia can blow up
the major source of its own revenue and
political influence in Russia by blowing
up to 10 billion Euro pipelines is a
world where anything that can happen so
I mean we can have a rational discussion
over why it's suicidal for Putin to use
nuclear nuclear weapons in the field and
I think it will be because that I think
that will lead to
a massive conventional response defeat
in the field and political crisis in
Russia so suicidal in that sense but
um but that would be a rational
discussion I mean post-nord stream too
I'm not sure that any kind of rational
discussion applies to the
decision-making of Putin and his inner
circle and what's the other thing that
blew your mind the kirchbridge explosion
well and uh no the other thing that blew
my mind was was that their their sudden
decision to to uh to to mobilize and uh
and and to Annex the uh Annex of
territories I mean just like on the
spread of the moment I mean they've been
planning you know they've been refusing
to do it for like months and months and
months and months and then suddenly they
do it on the spread of the moment and
they do it in a week and Dimitri
you know on the nuclear weapons side I
actually think in the short term it's
become less likely because Putin is
steadily escalating but mobilization was
his escalation answer to this war in the
short term
um he's clearly hoping that uh sending
hundreds of thousands of mobilized
troops even untrained into the conflict
is going to somehow change his fortunes
I think that's unlikely I think I think
he's mistaken on that front but over the
long term I think clearly the risks are
increasing I do think that the way he
thinks about nuclear weapons is
primarily as a signal and primarily is a
signal to the West not zielinski he's
convinced that zielinski is a pawn of
the west of course that's nonsense but
he I think truly believes that and um I
think if he does use a nuclear weapon
it's probably going to be more likely to
be a demonstration blast in a remote
area perhaps over a Black Sea maybe over
something symbolic like snake island but
with very little if any casualties and
as a way to show to Washington and
London the two places that Russia
believes are in control of everything uh
in the in a very conspiratorial way that
they tend to be to behave
um that um they're serious and um as a
way to try to get them to reign in
zelenski it won't work of course but um
I think that's how they're going to
think about this in Moscow very
interesting Dimitri and Owen thank you
so much for joining spectator TV
ukrainians have already started feeling
Putin's escalation as hundreds of
missiles were launched at them since the
kirchbridge explosion but more than just
general attacks Svetlana morinets author
of The Spectators today in Ukraine
newsletter sees a pattern in these
targets Putin is trying to destroy the
country's preparedness for winter she
joins the show
so it's philano welcome to spectator TV
and after the bombing of the Kirch
Bridge Putin has been launching a
counter-offensive through um sending
missiles into Ukraine um but you've
written for spectator that you think
there's a strategy here other than just
general destruction that he's targeting
certain things
yes but I would like to add that for
sure his aim is to threaten ukrainians
and like to make them panic but I think
that his main strategy Arista right now
is to bump Ukrainian power plants so the
Civil people will be left without
electricity and water and I think it is
like a rehearsal before winter
because he just tries to find the weak
spots in Ukrainian air defense system
and then in Winter he can bomb it and in
Ukraine the weather can reach like -25
in Winter and then that really will be a
problem because ukrainians were getting
ready for staying without gas this
winter but staying without electricity
too it's gonna be really tough so I
think he's just trying to see what he
can do and in Winter he will be like
launching more much more missiles and do
you think he has liked what he's seen so
far in terms of his capabilities has he
succeeded so far uh I would say yes and
no because uh in Monday and Friday they
launched like about 100 missiles and
half of them were shut down but you by
Ukrainian Army it is still not enough
but in February we couldn't shut down
anything and now it is half so he's
losing a lot of rockets and a lot of
money obviously but anyway uh
five thermal plants were hit
and some regions were without
electricity and now ukrainians were
asked voluntarily turn off the
electricity for four hours in the
evening four hours in the morning but it
seems that like in one week they will
have to do it like they it will be just
turned off by the government really
because uh
they try to repair the thermal power
plants and it takes time and
so ukrainians are already seeing the
consequences yeah but but people will
die because of how cold it gets as you
you mentioned I mean if you can't yes
especially people on the East where the
infrastructure was bombed uh
uh there will be no gas
ukrainians already started evacuation
from the east of Ukraine
but anyway we can't move Millions people
just for the rest you know it's
impossible and that's obviously
something that's very much on Ukrainian
people's minds on the government's mind
um what about the threat of the nuclear
um attack as well because that's
something that we here in London you
know we can talk about in abstract sense
but are people on the streets in Ukraine
are they concerned that they might be
the target of a nuclear attack for sure
they are concerned but they can't do
anything Ukraine is a non-nuclear
country unfortunately we gave up the
third largest nuclear Arsenal a lot of
years ago and
all of ukrainians are very regretted of
that right now but we can't
do anything and
the problem is that 40 million people
can't leave the country because of the
threat of nuclear attack we can't do
anything and what ukrainians hope that
if it happens that the West will react
but not only like with sanctions but
they expect that or they should rush
back or the Army comes to help our army
or something like that something more
than just words because we right now
Ukrainian Army is winning on the East we
are advancing only to day five
settlements were liberated in
Hearthstone region we can win this war
but not any clear War
yeah not without help Svetlana mornets
thank you so much for joining my teachtv
if you enjoyed spectator TV then why not
subscribe to the magazine go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
to try one month of the magazine imprint
and online for free
now will list trusts have to you turn on
even more of her tax cuts that's the
question dominating Westminster this
week as the Prime Minister barely
manages to study the ship
I'm joined by political editor James
Forsyth Deputy political editor Katie
Bush and assistant editor Isabelle
Hardman
Katie Isabelle and James welcome back to
spectator TV now Katie over the weekend
we heard about this charm offensive that
the new prime minister Liz truss is
going to be going on
um but last night we had her first
meeting with her back benches in the
1922 community and it doesn't actually
seem like this charm offensive is going
all that well yeah I think as as charm
offenses go
um I think this one has run to problems
pretty early on and we had lots of
briefings ultimately Liz truss hasn't
had much time in the common since
becoming prime minister
um partly of course because of the
funeral of the queen and also Party
Conference season so you had a situation
where uh her prime minister's questions
this week was her second Everest prime
minister yet what has happened between
the first and the second has been you
know very substantial you have had a not
so many budget which has backfired which
has completely changed I think the tone
of this trust's Premiership the problem
she's facing and I are all uh being
linked back to that of course the trust
as Government say there's Global factors
there too
um but it does just feel a world away
from you know just just a month ago and
therefore what we heard over the weekend
was Liz truss would try and restore
relations with the Parliamentary party
and this is uh by a few means uh
whatever interesting reaching out more
to MPS but you it is really with every
prime minister
um but part of this was to address the
1922 committee I think it's fair to say
that did not go to plan
um depending who you speak to I think
there are various blame games going
underway but I think what is pretty
clear from speaking to MPS from all
wings of the party is that their mood
was awful and was you know it was very
painful another MP described it to me as
brutal and it was largely hostile
questions so I think there are about two
fairly neutral questions
um I don't think they could be described
as positive and then the rest were uh
pretty critical now there's obviously
lots to criticize if you look at what's
happening in the markets um if you look
at the labor poll lead
um but I think what's unnerving Liz
trust supporters is how these questions
were not coming from one specific
faction they were spread all over and
actually
um during the two were outside the room
where this was happening one person here
there's lots of desk banging and and I
think often that can be read as support
for the Prime Minister after a few calls
it seems to me that death spelling might
have been actually after a question from
a Tory MP and who said we need to get
back to fiscal responsibility fiscal
credibility for the Tory party and
apparently that won the biggest chair of
the night and that is bad news for this
trust
so James you look at the situation in
the markets for your political column
this week for the magazine is the only
thing that will appease these Tory MPS
u-turns further u-turns on the tax cuts
from her fiscal event yeah and I think
this is one of the problems fillers
trust which is it's very hard to see how
you square the circle of doing enough to
reassure the markets uh but not blowing
up your political Authority in the
process and I think what is difficult
and you see this now is but you know we
know if you talk to the very senior
people in the government they admit that
you know one of the things that went
wrong with the mini budget was but there
were lots of things in there that the
markets weren't expecting the markets
are now expecting a u-turn on the
corporation tax cut
I don't think that as well is trust and
what's the question are right now as of
Thursday morning
um and so I think I think even on
October 31st they don't uh um you turn
on corporation tax the markets will be
surprised and potentially you'll have
more Market turbulence and that's the
risk the other thing to watch for is on
uh on Friday the bank ends it's the
banking ends its intervention in the
guilts market what then happens when the
markets reopen on Monday do we do we get
more um more volatility I I think even
if you take aside the banking
intervention the like it is worth
looking at what is happening to um debt
interest payments uh The Institute
fiscal studies estimates that they will
now be over 100 billion that is twice
what the obr were estimating back in
March and this obviously makes a whole
attempt to show that you're going to get
debt falling as a percentage of GDP much
more difficult and what makes these debt
interest payments so politically painful
is you don't don't get anything for them
there's not a single extra police
officer there's not a single extra
hospital or doctor despite the fact that
you're spending twice as much on debt
interest as you expect it to be back in
March
and Isabel in amongst all of this labor
seems to be getting on an election
footing um this week here summer has
made some Personnel changes can you tell
us about the plans um that the
opposition party are making
yeah so he
as you say announced that labor was
going on to an election War footing
saying that the instability of the
government is such that it could fall at
any moment and really what all of this
um was an attempt to was to say
we had a good conference but we know
we've still got a lot more work to do
because I think labor MPS and people
around Kirsten were so happy after uh
their sort of serious sober Party
Conference followed by the uh the
Meltdown in Birmingham uh that it would
be tempting for them to think
particularly given the the consistently
good poll leads that the party has and
that they've got it in the bag and uh
two problems there one is that voters
aren't really thinking about labor at
the moment they're just looking at the
toys and thinking oh my god
um and the other thing is that even if
labor does have an election in the bag
which you know actually I'm I'm not sure
is is yet the case uh it's not a party
that's that's fully ready to be a good
government and so that's why this was
briefed out as well it wasn't something
that just sort of
um happened under the radar it was it
was an attempt to say look we're we're
getting really serious now and so the
changes that Stormer um the Stormer
announced this week one is that the
party the headquarters are moving out of
their current location in South Side
another is that his chief of staff Sam
white
um has been amicably sacked
um and look I mean you know most people
uh in the UK have not heard of Sam white
um so it's very much an internal
Westminster thing but it does point to
um some of the tensions that have been
under the surface
um within the leader's office there have
been some some power struggles between
the many people around kirstama and
indeed there were Shadow cabinet members
who very much liked Sam white but didn't
think he was the sort of person who um
should be leading
um things from the from the leader's
office side as the party approaches
um at the really tough fight of um a
general election I think this doesn't
really resolve some of the some of the
bigger tensions though
um within the Shadow cabinet within the
team around starmer there's a debate
about
um how sort of how much emphasis to put
on green issues how far left to go
um you know we obviously had the two
policies at the labor conference um the
two main policies were basically a sort
of nationalizations of various things
and and I think you know talking to to
those in the shadow cabinet that they're
quite anxious that the party
um branches out from that doesn't end up
with a sort of Ed Miller Band
um 2.0 offer as it goes into the next
election because it's worth remembering
as much as those around starmer like Ed
miliband that the electorate did roundly
reject him back in 2015 so
um I think there's still a lot of
questions to be answered and one of the
biggest ones is actually where is
starmer in all of this you've got a lot
of people around him but but what does
he personally stand for what is stamina
tourism and we've obviously learned
quite a lot about what trussism is over
the past few weeks but we we still don't
really know what the leader himself
stands for and whether he's strong
enough uh to lead uh to lead a
government well they chaos with
adameliband surely can't be much worse
than what we've got at the moment as
well James and Katie thanks very much
this week Katie has also interviewed
Fiona Hill Theresa May is former Chief
of Staff for women with balls podcast
together with Nick Timothy Hill was
blamed for a lot of where the May
Administration first went wrong this is
her first interview since leaving
government and we can give a sneak
preview here
I felt like it was going to plan until
we got into the 2017 election
so on that Theresa May calls the
election it's
after they've been strong suggestions
she would not do that
um
what did you did you support the
decision to call an early election yeah
yeah
and I still think it's the right I think
it was the only thing that we had to do
because the majority was so slim and if
you look now back with hindsight how
difficult it has been
since then that there is no way that we
couldn't try out and have an election
and and based on as you said Katie the
polls indicated that we would win fairly
well
um what of course you can't make into
your thinking it's whether or not the
campaign you ultimately run has the
right momentum and I don't think the
2017 election campaign ever really had
the right momentum for a number of
reasons some in our gift and a lot
outside our control
but with election campaigns they're
almost like the voodoo that you know so
well
um
you can get luck
and you can also get bad luck and it
doesn't matter if you've got your
messages right or this and that right or
wrong
um sometimes it's just a quite
unquantifiable uh momentum or or indeed
otherwise it is always a bit of luck in
politics too yeah and life in general
what do you think went wrong that was in
the control I suppose of Theresa May
lives around her
um
well I I mean
I think I don't think I didn't get a
sense that she was really enjoying it
yeah
um
and I think that ultimately journalists
pick up on that in a campaign
um I think and I think it's documented
that I wasn't a supporter of the social
health care policy
um it was a very long campaign I mean it
took me weeks to catch up on sleep I
mean it really it's a tough campaign but
what was it about the social care policy
specifically that you just well I I
direct with Jeremy Hayward on it in
government we're actually number 10.
um and I knew that it had been tested
properly
um it's only been tested inside the
confines of the Civil Service my view
was to really get under the the skin of
of what what it was is that it should go
out to see like the king's fund or some
go out somewhere and be tried and tested
and then come back into government
I of course understand that we need to
do something about social health care
but I didn't feel like this policy which
was a complex policy complex if
something's complex to understand or to
communicate then it means that it hasn't
been tried and tested enough and I
didn't feel it had been yeah we see that
a lot in the current the recent
governments
um
was there a point you thought perhaps
the Tories would lose that election
was there a point before or if not I
wanted yeah
after the Manchester
um Arena bombing where we were traveling
by plane up to uh Manchester and the
window uh cockpit Windows shattered
and we had to drop
a couple of I'm terrible with metrics
I'm afraid but we had to um
[Laughter]
um and and I hadn't really been feeling
particularly great about the general
direction of the campaign anyway but
there was something about that moment
that that I I felt was a bit of an omen
and that I felt
like I said you know some bad things
happen during campaigns and um
and it's hard
you know to campaign for politics when
people have lost their life I mean you
know that's a really ugly thing had
happened you're not going out and seeing
strong and stable too much after that
yeah
um and so that slows everything down and
it has to it absolutely has to
um but overall I I just felt things were
not going to plan
and when the exit poll came through
because I remember coming through just
doing a live blog from next door and it
was a site like spit your tea out of
your mug moment what was your reaction
well um one of the best things I did
that uh day stroke evening was
um I got my sister to come into cchq
um and I I think it must have been
around
maybe 10 to 5 to 10 but as you can
imagine my memory is a bit blurry and
Andy Marr called me and told me
bought the exit poll Wards and I felt
like
basically I'd been kicked in the stomach
and I was aware that I was there in in
body but I wasn't really there at all in
my mind
um
and I was just so grateful for my sister
being there because you should kind of
directed me almost
um and then of course I had to tell Nick
and then I had a call from Theresa
asking me to go down to the constituency
which I did but I don't think I was
there very long she had her account and
then I was in another car coming back up
to cchq
and my sister had stayed on in the hotel
room I was staying and thank goodness
um and then I got there about five
o'clock in the morning and she'd already
packed up all my clothes and poured me
into a taxi and did a good sister yeah
she's a wonderful sister
um and I felt bad for my sister and
particularly for my brother during that
period because my brother was a BBC
journalist in Westminster and I can't
imagine how it would have felt for him
going into work the next day
felt quite guilty about that so all in
all it was what we probably would
describe as a low point in one's career
if you enjoyed that you can watch the
full interview on spectator TV this
Saturday
Putin and Trust might like to take some
notes from the one leader that does seem
to be doing quite well China's
presidency is about to be confirmed for
another five years as leader taking the
country back to maoist times I'm joined
by a Charles Barton a former Diplomat in
Beijing and Senior associate fellow at
the think tank rusi to discuss what this
might all mean
so Charlie Parker welcome to spectator
TV
um now on Sunday the another National
Party Congress will be opening in
Beijing in previous uh years and eras
this was a moment for leadership
reshuffles for the general secretary to
sometimes be changed and but is it fair
to assume that seizing pain will not be
stepping down over the coming weeks
how do you think live Brooks is offering
any off any odds at all on him stepping
down
I've not yet to come across a
commentator who thinks that he will so
we will all be immensely surprised if if
someone else takes over
so how has he got to this stage then
because the Chinese Communist Party must
be more cut through than even the
conservative party here in the UK and
yet Xi Jinping has you know had 10 10
years in power there's this informal
convention that General Secretary steps
down after 10 years after Chairman Mao
died and yet he's completely turned that
over on its head even though his two
predecessors followed that rule
yeah it's a very good question because
it's not it's not just there's precedent
uh that he's gone against he must have
offended an awful lot of people in China
I mean when you've given that perhaps a
million people have fallen and foul of
the discipline commission and you
multiply that by their families and
their supporters and adherents
Etc if you think about how he's offended
anyone who believes in religion by by
cutting out on that
um ethnic minorities uh all the people
who've lost out in in the Party part
struggles etc etc this must be a vast
massive opposition to him and yet nobody
dares to put their head above a parapet
and I don't think I I don't anticipate
that that anyone does and what he's done
is really controlled what I call the
seven centers of power inside the uh the
the the the Communist Party he controls
the Central Committee that's that's uh
205 full members and 172 alternates
people who don't get the vote but are
obviously still very powerful controls
basically the Pollock Bureau the 25
members uh of the that get chosen from
the Central Committee and he controls
the polyvirostana committee the seven
most well I might say most powerful
people but beyond that he also controls
the Secretariat of the of the Central
Committee which organizes business and
if you control what business a body does
that's very important he controls the
central military commission and the pla
the people's Liberation Army
um and the people's armed police which
is the backup for for the regime
and he controls the central commission
for discipline inspection which is a
very powerful weapon you start being
vaguely disloyable and you may find
yourself up on a discipline or a
corruption charge and the seventh set is
is the 2851
party County Secretary of a county level
um administrative region ranging from
anything sort of half a million to even
2 million Souls so these are powerful
people and gradually his his uh his
control is extending down to them and
then you add in the important party
um
departments organizations
the courts the procure
and a whole other Security Services he's
really got his people there and you look
what he's done he's put people he trusts
and knows in all those positions uh and
again when we come to the Central
Committee of this current
um just about to start
um party Congress
you know it's one of its roles is quotes
to elect uh the set the new Central
Committee the delegates elect a new
committee they don't of course I mean in
effect it's been already chosen because
of those 205 full members if you add in
people that are all bound to be there
almost ex-officio given the jobs that
they have the party provincial
secretaries the governors so that's the
number ones and twos that's over 60
people you know 40 military the heads of
the of of party departments etc etc you
take up pretty much all of those 205
places already I mean I would say well
over 190 probably 195 are already
decided uh and they're all seasonings
people
so you know he's very much in control so
is this saying something that we here in
the west
um Overlook which is that he's actually
the direction that he's taking China in
it's actually relatively popular or is
it saying something about his
personality and his smart his
intelligence uh that he's managed to
institutionally kind of grab all of this
power all that his Charisma is such that
everyone just wants to follow him which
I mean that last explanation is
something that I don't really see I mean
I don't see in him the kind of
charismatic
um leader that Chairman Mao was to some
people so Charlie what do you put it
down as
well I think he's he's politically very
astute in terms of of the sort of uh I I
mean power in China is is red claw and
tooth and nail stuff
um and he's he's obviously navigates
that extremely well at what you hear
from insiders is that he's not
particularly intellectually intelligent
but as sure as how he he knows how to
how to play the power game is he popular
uh I don't think we we should discount
that in many ways I mean you're right I
don't think he has particularly he's not
particularly charismatic Etc but over
the last 10 years you know the the China
has and they played it very strongly in
the propaganda as well China has done
reasonably well
um people have have come out better than
they were 10 years ago they play the
Nationalist drum but how powerful China
isn't influential in the world and that
goes down well with the people the
question is whether in the last couple
of years that the shine is not coming
off that I mean not only because people
are very upset by the uh zero covid
policy and and the restrictions of
that's put on their life but because the
economy is now facing some very severe
headwinds I mean youth unemployment for
instance is around 20 I mean that's the
official figure so one presumes it might
even be higher
uh and so I think looking forward Xi
Jinping you know will not be as popular
and as I said at the start there are an
awful lot of people who have reason
to dislike him uh just as they're an
awful lot of people so far who have you
know been relatively supportive of what
he's achieved
so hedwig's I think is is it's going to
be tough in the in the third term
when it comes to these headwinds you
know when you look at zero covert or the
way that the economy is doing
you know a lot of it can be traced down
to see his own agenda his own policies
whether it's you know zero covered or
it's common Prosperity or something like
that so do you think we're going to be
seeing now that he's got a third term a
continuation of these main policies or
is he going to be changing Tech
well you know the phrase about Margaret
Thatcher comes to mind the lady is not
for turning and I just don't see Susan
being being that way inclined either I
mean he is very ideological I think he
is a firm believer in in what he calls
Marxism but in practice really is is
leninism the sort of nationalist
leninism uh although it is as in in
Steve sang the professor from science
phrase it is consultative language they
do consult
um they don't necessarily let that
consultation get in the way of a
decision when it really matters but but
he is very uh I think
dogmatic in the literal sense of the
word I mean he believes this this Dogma
in this this Theory and you know you
look back to
2013 the third plenum and there was a
lot of talk about reform and making the
market decisive in the role of
allocation of resources uh and and a
more refined State role well
um you know that reform
hasn't hasn't happened uh and I and on
the contrary I mean his strength in the
economy his strengthened party control
both by boosting the state owned
Enterprises but also mammothy increasing
um you know party sales and party
branches within private companies
I think it's very difficult to think
that suddenly after I mean it would be
such a an extraordinarily sharp U-turn
it would be a handbrake you know j-ton
or whatever it is that uh the these
fancy drivers do
um and I just don't think that's his
character looking at the external side I
mean the way that America is reacting
and increasingly perhaps other free and
open countries are reacting that too is
is is is is is hostile under reaction to
that is increased Hospitality on the
part of of cesium being in the Communist
Party
that too would be difficult to back off
from yeah it'd be interesting to see
when that unpopularity in in the party
will get to a Tipping Point Charlie
Parton thank you so much for joining
just expectated TV
pleasure Cindy
and finally what happened to leisurely
train travel with dining carts and
Poorman armchairs in this week's issue
Peter Hitchens reminisces the Golden
Arrow Route which went from London to
Paris Mars better than a Eurostar he
says which does that route now he joins
the shame
foreign
I didn't know about the Golden Arrow
trains until I read your piece well I'm
so pleased I've told you have you looked
it up I've looked it up but can you tell
us more about it it was the last the
last and lingering piece of Railway
luxury it was still still around you
could you took a a very comfortable
train from London Victoria to Dover and
then you you went to an Old-Fashioned
Ferry which had no room in it for cars
climbed off the end went through the
French customs in a proper shed men with
Horizon Blue uniforms stabbing her
passport and then you walked across the
railway as onto the flesh door the uh
the French version of The Golden Arrow
which is all lovely Pullman cars and in
those days they still hitched a steam
locomotive to that and as far as Emir
but it was it was an old 1930s thing
which the railways had run and it was I
I have to boast here I won a scholarship
and my parents said what would you like
as a reward for this I said I'd like us
all to go on the gold narrative Paris
because I was certain having looked
around me that this wouldn't last it was
something that would be gone soon like
ocean liners and all the other things
that still around and so I was
determined to do it and they so they
they wonderfully agreed and we all four
of us went and it was the most marvelous
journey and inside it was all beautiful
like a lot of things in the in the 1960s
but it was still it had it had a certain
Grandeur and and stateliness to it and
the service was beautiful and it was I'd
never had food like that before because
I'd never been to France I was just
beautifully cooked food taken seriously
and served seriously it was all right on
the other side the English bit was quite
you know but it was basically you've got
breakfast I think and then on the way
back you've got afternoon tea so the the
proper business of lunch was on the
French side as it ought to be right and
it ended with this extraordinary
Discovery for me that there was there
was actually a thing called coffee which
brought no relation to the noxious
fluids that I've been consuming under
that name in in in in Britain of the
times little nesc cafe and something
Garcia bottle and it was a complete
Revelation also it was just a wonderful
Journey the the
the countryside between Cali and Paris
is not too much it's not you're not
suddenly somewhere spectacularly foreign
but the the fact of being in this
marvelous train that was plainly
equipped and they're quite different for
anything else anybody ever rated for
most of the time so comfortable uh so
pleasantly old-fashioned and so
I suppose there was ceremony to it was
uh was it was a treason it was the first
time I'd ever gone to Paris and it was
stuck with me every time I went
afterwards that this was the ideal to
which one could Aspire but wouldn't but
never would again because the Golden
Arrow had been canceled that but I I
don't know how many times I did it
before the tunnel was built I lost count
but it was always that Great Lift of the
spirit as the train pulled out heading
for the channel and then the even
greater lift as you as you as you as the
French Quarters came on board the
steamer and then you've you've found
that the French train waiting on the
other side and it's an adventure
um very different from the Eurostar well
the Eurostar is great because you don't
know it's so much quicker you don't and
and there is that enormous convenience
and we'd all felt for a very long time
at a tunnel it was probably a good idea
and so when it was finally built I felt
I know Dick West used to swear never to
use it I think because she thought it
was I think in some ways rightly the end
of us is an island nation but I never
felt like that I thought okay I can now
get to Paris more quickly and the I do
remember what in the early years it was
it was different the way it is now
um the coloring of it was different you
could get slightly better food as I
recall
um and it just it it was now the the new
modernized one is it's very gray blue
and chilly feeling and it doesn't have
even the last lingering bits of ceremony
that the old one had is it because of a
pursuit of functionality I mean you say
it's fast I think it is very functional
I think it's a all high-speed trains are
I suppose a bit functional they have to
follow boring flat bits of landscape
because mountains and and
forests are nuisance for high-speed
Railway Engineers but it's also it
doesn't seem to be in any
huge imagination put into the uh
designing of everything
why do you have to traips
through that stupid luggage check it's
it's it's not an airplane yeah it's it's
excessive I mean it's disproportionate I
I've looked up I can't find for certain
but in I think the and someone may
correct me on this but I I looked up on
the details of the the bullet trains
that go through the Japanese islands for
instance and the amazing train that goes
through this was the got out base tunnel
in Switzerland that goes from
Switzerland through to Italy which is as
long and as deep I don't believe they do
that for them so why do they do it first
passport control I love I've always
liked possible control I love the
rituals I love borders I think borders
are great they're very thought provoking
and interesting and uh and I I I've
always loved borders in any case here is
the strange thing in the London borough
of some Pancras as used to be there
isn't an ex-slave of France it's really
odd but once you're through that once
you're through that border control
you're in France so why isn't it more
French yeah that's strange
Subterranean area where you sit around
waiting this is the other thing waiting
to be called for your trade as if it was
an airplane which it isn't like you keep
stressing this point it's not an
airplane it's a train where you have to
sit it's not at all French instead of
just getting on a train it's like
Heathrow and why can't you when I get on
a train at Paddington or Kings Cross or
Louisville Street I find out what the
platform is I go to the platform I show
my ticket I show my passport you've
asked and get on it
but with the eurocyte you have to sit
around until your train is called as if
it was an airplane it doesn't I have to
say this again it isn't an airplane
so Peter in preparing to talk to you I
came across some of these amazing
companies that kind of recreate the gold
narrow experience the price tag was
pretty expensive it's about four
thousand pounds a trip from London to
Prague or somewhere like that for one
night per person would you but would you
would you want to do something no this
is this is this is this is
museums where you can eat the exhibits
it's not real life the thing about the
golden era was it was real it was an
actual thing you could just anyone who
could pay could turn on it was an actual
service there were cheaper carriages
where you didn't get as good Services
what we got but it was uh anybody could
get on it and travel as if they wanted
to for a faster service between London
and Paris and it was part of normal
Railway life Justice restaurant cars and
so very recently we're part of normal
Railway existence and suddenly someone
seems to have decreed that they're all
to be they're also being destroyed
they're hardly any to be found anywhere
anymore yeah do you think it's a wider
demand for functionism across Society
not just in train travel but you know
you talk about airplanes but actually
you know Once Upon a Time plane stud
used to be much more comfortable than
what we've seen now they do architecture
so they also crashed more well
architecture also used to be more
beautiful less functional
architecture you can do this is if you
travel
um Beyond Brussels on the Euro stop on
the way to Germany through liege there
is the most beautiful modern station the
station of the edges is absolutely
breathtakingly lovely and it's entirely
modern and it's a demonstration of what
you could do if you really wanted to so
it doesn't need to be old to be
beautiful there are a lot of a lot of
the European Railway stations are rather
good especially Antwerp which is a sort
of Cathedral Railways which everybody
should go to but the whole atmosphere of
it was that here it was
before the the modernizers went to work
there was a there was another Europe
of slightly slower much more comfortable
much more enjoyable lying there for
anybody who's prepared to use trains and
for when I once I started doing it in
the 60s I I then intensively did it for
years and years in the 70s and Aces
traveling all over Europe by train as
far as I could get and there was still
this network of old-fashioned I won't
say luxury but pleasure of going by
train yeah
Leisure but the sense of adventure of
the of it being
that had been proper travel which you
don't really get now and also running
through the old
the old Mistral which runs Europe
Express which used to run down from
Paris to Marseille actually went down
the Rowan Valley it doesn't anymore
because their own values is there's not
very much fun for high-speed trains to
negotiate because you wind along but you
wind along the road past all the
wonderful Vineyards recognizing the
names of the things you've been drinking
such as
you actually go past it and it's a
marvelous Journey after that train it's
an incredible trade wonderful
air-conditioned High riding with a
copper bar in it you could sit in and
look out at the landscape
Francois mitron gave that train to Fidel
Castro and I encountered it many years
later in Cuba oh wow between Havana and
Santiago on my way to Guantanamo and the
train was still recognized to be the one
but it's not in the same state as it was
then 20 years in the hands of the of the
um of the Cuban socialist republic is
not good for not good for Trans but it
was still an adventure
well Peter you must write that for
another article at some point soon and
thank you so much for joining us like
taste TV
that's it for this week once again
thanks to Canada wealth management for
sponsoring the week in 60 minutes they
will provide you with the expertise you
need to help you build your wealth with
confidence visit candywealth.com for
more information
and don't forget to subscribe to The
Spectators YouTube channel just click
the red subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you
[Music]